bitte jetzt bitte ich wusste er musste
hey leute herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge challenge accepted mal
wieder und zwar er wird mir heute
challenge gegeben ich darf nur das hier
machen nur langsam laufen also ich darf
nichts sprint ich möchte das alles ja so
ein bisschen mehr auf den mount blade
server machen welche server vielmehr
feier von engern vom ganzen aufbau ip
steht immer in der beschreibung haben
wir geil ich bin auch ultra mittlerweile
hier kann ich nur schreibe aber damit
schon leute wird geschrieben
es ist einfach viel besser organisiert
mit servern und mit dem was wir hier am
rechts am rand haben soll wird was führt
wie viele punkte man selber hat was die
website ist wie viele leute vom support
online sind und so was alles das ist
viel besser und ich würde sagen ich
mache das ganze bei super special ops
survival games ist es so wenn man gute
sachen hat dann hat man quasi gewonnen
das ist einfach so diner mit einem
holzschwert kann noch soviel skill haben
wir trotzdem einen nicht allen besiegen
kann deren diamant schwerer bei super
smash mops ist es allerdings so jeder
hat seine standardklasse und man findet
nicht noch mehr sachen seitdem gestern
also dass der nachricht deswegen hab ich
mir gedacht ich mach das bei super
special ops und ich nehme quasi eine
klasse super special ops ist es okay
folge alles geht schon direkt in zehn
sekunden los egal welche klasse man
nimmt es ist man es immer viel viel
besser wenn man sprintet trotzdem das
ein windows skelett und ich darf dich
nicht sprinten bei mir ist es so ich
sprinte immer auch wenn ich jemand
angreife zwei zentimetern entfernung ich
weiß auch gar nicht wie ich die sprünge
schaffen soll ohne zu sprinten
also super smash mops ohne sprinten ist
diesmal die tschechische können wir
weiterhin challenges in die kommentare
schreiben
ich weiß nur dass ich versuche dann aber
ich versuche nicht zu gewinnen das ziel
ist einfach hals zu schaffen also dass
ich das einfach zu machen einfach machen
ist es jedoch psychische selber weg
einfach machen
ich stehe dahinter um 2 sekunden von 30
von sosa ersetzt
nein
okay gut ich bin hier um drauf bin noch
keinmal gesprintet loskommen jetzt kommt
verpiss dich eltern liegt darin flieht
nein was ist denn hier wird jemand kann
nicht nur mitleid erzeugen möchte so
einfach los crafter los ich hab nur noch
vier von diesen mann verpisst euch doch
was schleudert er mir denn hier so viele
kacke hin
ich finde ich bin einmal ganz kurz
gesprintet
ok ich darf nicht drin das ist eine
scheiß angewohnheit dass man immer
sprintet wenn man ihnen vorüber fliegen
will oder so ich spiele das dann immer
so dass es zehn minuten werden kann auch
sein dass ein paar das sich stark
gemacht
es kann auch sein dass ein paar also
dieser tiefe des events starkes weiß ich
aber ich darf jetzt darf ich springe das
ist so ärgerlich ist tot
wenn ich das gewinnen okay die anderen
beiden der eine campen oder ganz hinten
das soll auf jeden fall auch ein cooler
typ kommen desktop gut die hälfte der
killer
so kommt es kommt jetzt mal mein image
hin und ich wechsele jetzt mal in hof
image jetzt bin ich nämlich hinter dem
typen hh das war nämlich das ganze was
ich zeigen wollte mir das skelett bei
mutter skelett kann man nämlich richtig
für mich so unendlich wenn ich nicht um
getötet wenn ich mich nicht springen
kann
beim mutter skeleton kann man nämlich
war das war gut das war richtig gut beim
boulevard skeleton kann man nämlich
alter gut jetzt habe ich schnell zum
image gewechselt beim uhr skeleton kann
man nämlich so ein image dahin schicken
cook und jetzt gleich zum turm zum image
zb das jetzt nicht mit gewalt gestoppt
werden das kann doch echt nicht sein
dass sie da hinten
jetzt kann ich nicht zum image wert
wechseln jetzt bin ich hier das image
jetzt bringe ich diesen typen geben um
only da springt jetzt weg blöde pizza er
wo ist der dritte eigentlich also wer
das skeleton ist echt kann man glaube
ich nur spielen wenn man sich das kauft
mit ultra oder so fällt die spinne
bringt einfach über die felder einfach
runter
die opfer bekommen jetzt kriegst du
jedoch nur mit von mir jetzt wächst ich
mich zum in münchen jetzt kann ich den
boxen hier und jetzt der tod das ist man
kann so geile taktiken man jetzt kann
ich wieder zum image gehen
man kann sogar eine taktik mit einem
image waren wo alter wenn ich das
gewinnen würde wie krass dass bitte wäre
ohne zu sprinten
einfach nur weil ich diese taktik mit
dem router skeletten habt also das ist
nur das skelett und super special ops
ist zurzeit so was von meiner lieblings
modus und das geile ist auch mann
kannten wir können es alle spielen wir
können es wirklich alle spielen weil
alle war das knapp weil alle können
dieses spiel spielen man muss nicht
premium haben und da spielen zu können
es kann wirklich jeder spielen das ist
halt so das geile darin junge ich werde
mir die ganze kg in das wissen nützt dir
nix alter von justus dahinden junge
leute halt alles von 54
was bringt ihnen das denn in diesem café
die kann ich mit einem schlag um bringen
ja kaum noch ein ja geil fußball hier
direkt wieder tot
woods einmal den und jetzt liegt sie da
oben hin und jetzt spricht sie davon
image von denen man du bist doch feige
alter wie feige kann man denn sein
ich komme da nicht mal hoch weiß außer
so halter wie feige ist er denn bitte
wie feige man wie pussy haft ist der
denn einmal im zweikampf verkackt 12
cover der hat facto eine ganze stunde
dabei habe ich mir keinen vorteil nicht
verstanden ich glaube ich hätte sogar
noch eine runde dran weil das einfach
richtig spaß was zu ohne zu sprinten
ihr könnt übrigens auch immer dann so
video antworten mäßig erstellen so von
wegen hacker scheiße also ich hab noch
ein leben mit muss vorsichtig sein und
er fliegt wieder zu seiner scheiß
plattform
ich sehe schon kommen erstickt wird in
der ganzen komischen teile dazu
altersjahr man ok eins gegen eins
ihr könnt mir übrigens video antworten
schicken in dem ihr dann dahinter in
klammern
ich habe einfach geworden war geworden
und letztlich sprinten
ich habe ohne dass hier gewonnen und mit
sprinten kommen wenn man doppel spielen
kommt so schnell voran und ich hab's
einfach ohne sprinten
also können wir auch wieder antworten
machen dir dann einfach celik accepted
contractor nicht sprinten oder ein
weiteres video antwort ich mach das
nochmal mit dem hier und was gelten ist
echt das alles was es gibt weil man
halten durch dieses dass man im winter
image machen kann hat man sogar eine
taktik möglichkeit das richtig geil
na ja heute übrigens mehr checks äbte
dann gebt einfach den daumen hoch weil
dadurch sehe ich aber ob ihr das feiert
was ich mache oder nicht wenn jetzt halt
nicht wenn ihr die serie findet das im
challengers schreiben können ich muss
das dann machen dann starting lake 76
ist auch voll geil gemacht
dann gibt halt einen daumen runter die
körpergewichts auf der challenger
schreiben die ich dann in real life
machen soll wie zum beispiel lässt sich
dort nur betont hat das gemacht lobt
werdet ihr bald auch auf meinem finden
dass eine wäscheklammer nehmen oder
sowas in durch die nase kommt jetzt
sitzt ja nicht einfach mit mir anlegen
oder bis ich mit mir anlegen er kam
komplett com loskommt
okay okay
ich bin die schritte ganz kurz karmann
ist es echt so gewöhnen schocken
gestorben tacke ja so ist es auch gut
auf jeden fall
ich heiße kann sein dass die alle auf
mich gehen scheiße dieses place teil
geht nur auf mich gab noch ein bisschen
angst ich hab vor die displays gegen den
geht nur auf mich junge stars wir
während dieses plays pink alter junge
sucht euch leute geht nicht nur auf
milch kämpft euch doch mal gegenseitig
alter auch ich bin jetzt gespendet damit
11 mehr jene okay das tut
ich muss mich mal ganz kurz regenerieren
ich verstecke mich jetzt einfach mal
findet michaela hofmann nicht dass name
das name der name da vorne kommt näher
nein junge warum gehen ihn auf mich
bekräftigt aber gegenseitig das beste
wenn ich hier bleibe kämpft euch doch
mal gegenseitig nicht nur auf mich ich
werde der computer hierhin gut egal wir
machen jetzt los
auch der liebe nicht mehr schreibt okay
dass er schon mal ganz gut sport bei dem
ok
die spinne krieg jetzt das kann doch
nicht sein das kann doch nicht sein
scheißegal ich jetzt hier raus kacke
okay gut
ich hänge doch eine dann weil das halt
echt doof dass der tunnel aber spricht
so waiting for players will sie
eigentlich jetzt genug oder sogar 44
spieler den kann ich denn sonst noch
nehmen die spiele ist eigentlich auch
ganz geil aber ich würde irgendwie gern
noch mal super ultra klassen nehmen
damit die davon noch mal so ein bisschen
was zu sehen bekommt schicken soll auch
ganz gut damit schicken habe ich zum
beispiel das gemacht wo ich mit cross
darüber geredet habe was wäre wenn das
internet auf einmal weg wäre
da haben wir schicken genommen das ist
auf jeden fall folge hiermit kann nicht
so schicken werfen so glaube ich nie
hiermit kann nicht werfen trächtig und
jemand schlagen und damit weiß ich gar
nicht mehr glauben trächtig war auch
feile und genau jetzt da wenige sprinten
musste gleich mal nicht die map dass die
welt die zum mega klein rechtsklick
achter kommt raus und linksklick
linksklick
keine ahnung was hiermit ein günstiges
hier kommen halt zu unseren lasten neben
ihm stets um typen ich geh jetzt extra
noch das glück ja lustig grün
ich hab noch drei leben ich verstecke
mich jetzt einfach mal hier geht alle
weg bevor junge ist es ein epischer
kampf und das klappt ein herz und ich
darf nicht sprinten und ich darf nicht
sprinten online scheiße los dass kaka
ohne zu sprinten
ich weiß gar nicht was ich wie ich es
vor allem in der ersten runde noch
rasiert hätte wenn nicht sprinten dürfte
sie ist und welche kraft die zweite
runde war einfach so dass genug
bis dahin muss ein hotel
kommt verpiss dich verpiss dich jetzt
verpiss dich des todes tot damit man das
kann es nicht sein wie viel leben hast
du denn noch legal
ich kann ja nicht mal springen das ist
so traurig aber keine critical hits card
machen alter wie kann das denn sein
ich schlag den ganze zeit ich boxen und
ich hab keinen leben verloren bin ich
tot
die junge diese scheiß kletter hinten
danke dass ich die spenden darf ist das
paket
computer ist tot ist es nicht aber diese
kulanz diese einfach nur richtig stark
um so mit schwertkämpfen oder kann hat
ein spinnennetz angeflogen l sind die
spinnen drin
ja komm mir kommen comcom heuer endlich
mankell ich habe immer noch zwei leben
auch so der erst hat auch noch drei er
gut dann bin ich gar nicht so schlecht
gerade erhält auch schmeckt aber schade
dass ich nicht so erleben so richtig
schnell jetzt mal aufladen dorfplatz
überleben auf ich werde jetzt mal ganz
kurz kommen
da ist das hühnchen wir kennen uns doch
so hughes irgendwie jetzt mit einem
mädchen getötet
komm lass mich nahe in ein scheiß klett
alter hakt das so bei dem mir lieber
demag das also leute an alle die jetzt
einschalten und das nicht verstanden
habe ich dafür finden
nein ein leben als einen einleben okay
der ersten 30 muss jetzt ein bisschen
defensiver vorgehen
ich glaube es erst mal hier da ist einer
da oben sind zwei okay ich hoffe man
mich sieht keiner
ich bin ja auch eigentlich nur so ein
kleines hühnchen oder eigentlich dürfte
ich nur ein kleines hündchen seien
deswegen sollte man eigentlich nicht so
heftig sehen
ok kommen da hinten könnte ich mir jetzt
mal vor jolo war das knapp vor mir ist
dieses geld op alter was hat denn der
bitte von range rover auf mich schießen
kann
ok ok ruhig bleiben lukas ruhig bleiben
halbes herz halbes herz ich will auf
jeden fall nicht als letzte darunter
gehen
ich weiß es ist wer auf jeden fall
normal weil ich ja nicht finden dürfte
aber die da hinten bekämpfen sich da
muss als maler von stämmen an einer von
den beiden muss ja ein leben haben
ich liebe mein leben euro war mit
gewinnen hat er mich gesehen
bitte lasst mich nur jetzt bitte ich
muss der wusste er wusste wo ist der typ
ich glaube nein außer sehen konnte war
dfb damit die so langsam stirbt junge
spieler schon jetzt wie viele eltern aus
alter wie verhält er denn aus
das kann doch nicht sein junger wie viel
geld er denn aus jetzt ist auch noch
aber das kann doch nicht sein das war
einfach jungen attacke pur von mir wie
konnte das denn aus halten sich doch als
letzter heruntergegangen
das erste war erst das zweite wahl ist
das letzte wort bei alter
er springt dann noch so hoch erklärt er
auch tut wir beobachten dass immer noch
so ein bisschen
ich würde mal sagen nee ich glaub ich
glaube trotzdem dass das dieser gruben
drama gruben gräber verliert conny
stream ja wo denn wohl im boden
denn wer denn hier in screen machen wenn
wir sind unsichtbar
da sind wir uns sichtbar nicht abbrechen
ich glaub ich glaube wirklich der gruben
gräber gewinnt das neuer der dragon paro
gewinnt das noch eigentlich müsste das
eigentlich müsste grün ok gruppen
grammaturen angola muss noch an
anschaffen alter dem muss ich auch mal
testen für euch das ist echt heftig weil
ich meine dass der so viele attacken von
mir ausgehalten hat und ich habe immer
wieder skeleton also immer wieder diese
lag blaster dann wieder dies dann wieder
das scheiße ich glaub der bekannten
speedminton naja freuen wenn es euch
gefallen hat mir davon haben wollt
erlebten daumen hoch exchanges und die
kommentare schreiben will ich sagen
jetzt beim nächsten mal wieder unter